i'm handling the death part they're
handling the life part
can you delve into that a little bit
what do you mean so much death we're
bloody exhausting these children
like the children the animals there's
dogs there's cats everywhere i look
there's
more life that's probably a dog hair in
my mouth right now
it's just uh it invades every every
facet of my being
see that's why you're supposed to have
children when you're young and stupid
instead of old and wise
yeah i see that now thank you very much
i wish i
met you when i was 20. i possibly
wouldn't have been able to
absorb the information then either no no
that's another problem i think you have
to have children when you're young by
accident
that's how i did it it worked out really
well